تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مشهدا
وصفوه بالسحر واللوحه الفنيه لمناطقه
صحراويه شاسعه شمال السعوديه تكتسي
بالورود الارجوانيه على مد البصر بعد
امتار غزيره وزوار يتوافدون من كل المناطق
كافه للاستمتاع بهذه الاجواء
[موسيقى]
على مدى 27 عاما يقف هذا الجندي الامريكي
المتقاعد هنا في نفس المكان مرتديا زيه
العسكري وحاملا باقه من الورود على امل
عوده محبوبته سيسيليا في نفس المكان الذي
تقابله فيه اول مره وبعد ان فرقتهما
الحياه ضل يبحث عنها يوما تلو الاخر لكن
دون جدوى حتى قرر ان لا يتزوج ابدا حتى
تعود له ليضرب هذا الجندي مثلا للوفاء
والحب على مواقع التواصل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
رجال اطفاء الاتراك كانوا يقومون بعمليات
البحث والانقاذ في مدينه غازي عنتاب
المتضرره من الزلزال بروزما من الدولارات
ظهرت لهم قرب رجل انتشروه من تحت الانقاض
فاذا بالذي عثروا عليه يزيدوا عن مليونين
دولار حملوها مع اغراض اخرى عثروا عليها
وسلموها الى الشرطه
[موسيقى]
مشاهد متداوله لزعيم كوريا الشماليه كيم
جونغ اون وهو يصطحب ابنته لحضور مباراه
كره قدم محليه وظهرت ابنته تجلس بجانبه في
الصف الامامي بينما تجلس شقيقته المعزوله
في ابعد مقعد في المنصه اصطحاب زعيم
البلاد ابنته للمره السادسه علنا يعد
اشاره جديده الى انها قد تخلفه في الحكه
وفي الحكم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء